[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع اليها الاختيار استهلها بابره
العالم
خطر تفجير سد نوفا كخوف كي يرتفع مع منسوب
تسربي مياهه والاستخبارات الامريكيه تتهم
موسكو بالهجوم
بعد توصيات سعوديه امريكيه طرف الصراع في
السودان يستانفان محادثات وقف اطلاق النار
في جده
تزامنا مع زياره بلينكن الى السعوديه
واشنطن تؤكد التزامها بتعزيز الشراكه
الامنيه مع الرياض
بعقد يمتد لثلاث سنوات اتحاد جده السعودي
يتفق مع كريم بنزيما قادما من ريال مدريد
[موسيقى]
انهيار وان كان جزئيا الا ان تداعياته
خطيره لا بل خطيره جدا نتحدث هنا عن
انفجار سد نوفا كخوفكا الواقع في الاجزاء
التي تسيطر عليها روسيا من منطقه خرسون
الجانبان الروسي والاوكراني تبادل
الاتهامات حول الطرف الذي يقف وراء الحادث
ليذهب الجانبان الى مجلس الامن وهو ما
وافق عليه الاخير الذي سيعقد الجلسه خلال
ساعتين من الان والى ان يجتمع المجلس
ترتفع نسبه المخاوف من الاثار التدميريه
التي قد تلحقها الحادثه بالمناطق التي تقع
على يمين نهر النيبرو وعن عمليات الاجلاء
فقد انقذ نحو 17 الف مدني بينما بقي اكثر
من اربعين الفا معرضين للخطر
[موسيقى]
الهدف من هذا التفجير حسب المعطيات
المتوفره ما يلي بعد فشل العدو في تحقيق
نجاح في العمليات الهجوميه يعتزم العدو من
اجل تعزيز امكاناته نقل الوحدات والمعدات
من محور خرسون الى منطقه العمليات
الهجوميه مما سيضعف مواقعه على محور خرسون
الى حد كبير
وفي اول تعليق امريكي على التفجير رجحت
الاستخبارات الامريكيه وقوف موسكو وراء
الهجوم على نوفاكاخوفكا قبل ذلك نشرت
وسائل الاعلام اوكرانيه صورا بالاقمار
الصناعيه للساد الواقع في خرسون جنوبي
اوكرانيا قبل وبعد تدمير وتظهر الصور
انغمار المنطقه المحيطه بالسد بالمياه هذا
واكد تسلطات المواليه لروسيا في خرسون ان
منسوب المياه في المدينه وصل الى اكثر من
11 مترا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا بالموسكو عبد الجواد
الرشد مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد اولا
التعليق الرسمي الروسي خلال هذا النهار
جوله سريعه على الاجواء من هناك وكيف يرى
الجانب الروسي والشارع الروسي هذا التفجير
مساء الخير ليالي يعني الكرملين تحدث
اليوم ووصف هذا العمل بالتخريب
المتعمد ووصفه بالعمل الارهابي مشيرا الى
ان كييف قامت بهذا الشيء للفت الانذار حول
الخسائر الكبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه والتي
دار الحديث عنها في الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه هذا الاعلان تم على لسان الكرملين
وايضا المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الدفاع
وايضا اضاف وتحدث عن ان خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تجاوزت حاجزه ثلاثه الاف
جندي بالاضافه الى اكثر من 100 عربه
عسكريه مدرعه خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
تقف وراء هذا العمل هذا بما يخص الاعلان
الرسمي اما الاعلان الرسمي من سلطات
نوفا كخوفكا المواليه لموسكو فتحدثت بان
هذه الضربه جاءت خلال الليل هذه المنطقه
حساسه هدفت من ورائها كييف الى قطع بطريقه
ما تحركات موسكو ومنعها من الوصول الى
مناطق مختلفه ابرزها يكمن في اديسا وفي
خرسون وفي مناطق زبروجا مع الابقاء على
مخرج لاوكرانيا على البحر الاسود بما يخص
الشارع الروسي طبعا والمجتمع هو موضوع
موضوع اليوم الكثير من التحليلات السياسيه
راحت تراقب الموضوع راقب التحركات
الكاميرات وصور الاقمار الصناعيه بعض
الانباء والتقارير تتحدث عن ان هي قامت
بضخ كميات اكبر من المياه من مدينه
دينيبرو يوم امس لرفع مستوى المياه في
النهر لتكثر الكميه عند ضرب السد بينما
الشارع الروسي يراقب عن كسب ما يحدث لا
يمكن اخفاء القلق الكبير ومقاطع الفيديو
والمعلومات التي يتم نشرها حول هذا
الموضوع خاصه ان الكثير من المناطق الان
تعيش موجه من الفيضانات التي ملات كل مكان
البيوت تتحرك كما يشاهد الجميع على مقاطع
الفيديو فوق مياه النهر بالاضافه الى تلف
الاراضي الزراعيه وتعرض كثير من المناطق
والقرى على الجانبي النهر لعمليات الفيضان
الليالي اذا طبعا عبد الجواد سنبقى
بالساعات المقبله لرص هذه الصوره من هناك
شكرا لك عبد الجواد الرسم مراسل العربيه
حدثنا من موسكو
[موسيقى]
قاموا الليله بتفجير السد محطه كخوفك
للطاقه الكهرومائيه في الساعه الثانيه
وخمسين دقيقه حدث الانفجار لقد كان انفجار
متعمدا ومجهزا تماما كانوا يعرفون بالضبط
ما كانوا يفعلون فقط تخيل حجم المياه التي
يحتفظ بها هذا السد انه احد اكبر الخزانات
في اوكرانيا لا تزال الفيضانات في المناطق
الجنوبيه من بلادنا مستمره منذ الليله
الماضيه عاش ما لا يقل عن 100 الف شخص في
هذه المناطق قبل الغزو الروسي ما لا يقل
عن عشرات الالاف لا يزالون هناك 80 بلده
وقريه مغموره بالمياه لقد بدا الاخلاء
بالفعل وهذه مجرد عواقب اوليه
[موسيقى]
اتخذت الحرب في اوكرانيا منحا جديدا
وخطيرا بعد تفجير سد نوفا كخوفكا لما
يمثله هذا السد من اهميه استراتيجيه كبرى
سد نوفا كخوفكا سيطرت عليه روسيا في بدايه
الحرب ويقع السد على نهر نيبرو على بعد 30
كم شرقي مدينه خرسون في جنوب اوكرانيا كما
نشاهد هنا ويقطن مشاهدينا هذه المنطقه
اكثر من 16 الف شخص يحتوي خزان السد على
ما يقدر بنحو 18 كيلومترا مكعبا من المياه
ويبلغ ارتفاع هذا السد 30 مترا وعرضه طبعا
مئات الامتار تفجير هذا السد الضخم يعادل
تاثيره تاثير انفجار قنبله نوويه وسيؤدي
طبعا الى عواقب بيئيه واقتصاديه
وتكنولوجيه ضخمه جدا وفقا هنا طبعا
لمسؤولين روس واوكرانيين تحدثوا بعد تفجير
هذا السد وخلال اربعه ايام
المياه المنطقه برماتها لاجل ذلك يجب
اجراء المدنيين والحيوانات باسرع وقت ممكن
لتجنب الكارثه لاسيما بعد تدمير اربعه
توربينات في منطقه ومحطه نوفا جنوبي
اوكرانيا الذي سيزيد من ارتفاع منسوبه
المياه طبعا الى عشره امتار هذه الكارثه
ستخلف عواقب وخيمه وخطيره على البشر حيث
هناك نقص مياه في خزان نوفاكاخوفكا سيؤدي
طبعا مشاهدينا الى جفاف الحقول في جنوب
اوكرانيا وهو ما تحدث عنه كل المسؤولين
كما ان عشرات المصانع الكبرى ستتوقف
نهائيا عن العمل بسبب قله المياه وانقطاع
الكهرباء مما سيؤدي طبعا الى عواقب بالغه
في هذه المنطقه في المرحله المقبله
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا منك
السفيرشو ماكوف ودبلوماسي السابق ومن
موسكو
المحلل السياسي سابدا معك سعاده السفير من
كييف اليوم هناك تبادل بالاتهامات من قام
بتفجير السد ومن المستفيد من هذا التفجير
طبعا اذا اخذنا الروايتين الروايتين ممكن
تصديقهما بالمنطق ولكن بالروايه الروسيه
ضد كيف ضد اكياف اليوم في الفتره والاونه
الاخيره تمتهن او تعتمد ما يسمى بنشر
الفوضى على الحدود الروسيه بسبب الاخفاقات
التي تتحدث عنها روسيا بعمليه المضاده او
بالعمليه العسكريه كيف تردون على هذه
النقطه بالذات او كيف ترى هذا الموضوع
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته تحيه
طيبه امينه اوكرانيا روسيا
ارهابيه ولكن دعونا دعونا نعود الى بدايه
حرب عندما روسيا هجمت على محافظه خرسون
ولا ما كانت عمليه لتراجع قوات مصالحه
اوكرانيا من نافاخ ان الجيش اوكرانيا
لتدمير
لوقف هجوم لوضع هجوم الجيش روسيا تمام جيش
اوكرانيا لا يدامر اي بنيه تحتيه اساسيه
في هذا المنطقه ولكن في شهر نوفمبر عندما
اوكرانيا حررت ضيفت غربيه ونحن نتذكر
غربيه يعني ومن مدينه خرسون الروس ادام
ركون بنيه تحقيق للطاقه وكل البنيه تحطيط
اساسيه على الضفه الغربيه في محافظه خرسون
وايضا داخل مدينه والان اكيد في الضوء
هجوم مضاد الواقع من القوات مصالحه روسيه
للروس هلع وبهذا سببهم اتدمروا هذا الصاد
ليوظف هجومه
نحن الان نشاهد بان نتيجه هذه العمله
الارهابي انه كبير بصراحه
لاوكرانيا
بان هذا التفجير يهدد
يهدد بمحطه نوويه زبادي
تسريب الاشعاع في حاله
خصوصا لاوروبا ولكن عن هذه النقطه تحديدا
ساتحدث الى الدبلوماسي
السابقني يعني هذه النقطه هي جوهر الحديث
الان لماذا لم تقوم اوكرانيا اذا كانت
تريد تفجير هذا السد بتفجيره عندما كانت
بالمنطقه الغربيه اليوم البعض يعتبر بان
سلاح القنبله او سلاح السدود والمياه هو
احد الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه التي تستعملها
موسكو بحروبها كيف تردون على هذه النقطه
تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين والدي في
الكريمه اعتقد نظرنا الى الوضع بطريقه
موضوعيه وحتى حياديه لشك انه ليس من مصلحه
موسكو ما حدث من تفجير هذا السد الان في
هذا الوقت بالذات لماذا اذا اخذنا
الاعتبار ان روسيا تعتبر واكادت وما زالت
تعتبر مناطق زباروجي اخرسون وبما في ذلك
طبعا
عليها القوات الروسيه منذ زمن بعيد اذا
كانت تعتبرها ارضا روسيه لها فلماذا هي
يعني تختم على هذه الخطوه التي سوف تسبب
تبعاته وانعكاسات سلبيه جدا يعني هي تنعكس
على وضع البيئه على الوضع الصحي على
الطبيعه بالاضافه الى الانعكاسات
والتداعيات السلبيه للغايه على الزراعه
فهذه المنطقه سوف تكون روسيه كما ترى
وتقتنع بذلك السلطات الروسيه فهل هي تطلق
نار على نفسها لاعتقد ان هذا الموقف منطقي
وهذا اولا ثانيا بالنسبه للهجوم الاوكراني
ابط عمليه الهجوم المضاد بعدما اثبت
الاوكران بانه ليس عمليه واسعه شامله انما
عمليات يعني متعدده ومتكرره بمناطق معينه
ابطاء الهجوم هل من مصلحه موسكو ان تقوم
بهذا التفجير لابطائه
وانا لا اعتقد ذلك لانه
ما يكفي منها وسائل اخرى كفيله بصد هذا
الهجوم وهذا ما تدل عليه نتائج المعارك
والعمليات العسكريه التي شهدتها هذه
المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه لا شيما
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
وبنفس الوقت يعني روسيا كما قلت ليس من
مصلحتها ان تسبب ضررا بنفسها لان هذا
الوضع اذا افترضنا مثلا ان روسيا هي وراء
هذا التفجير فهل هي تلحق ضررا بنفسها وهي
تبقى وتعتجم يعني البقاء هناك للابد كما
تقول موسكو هذه المناطق هي تابعه لروسيا
هل هي بهذه التبعات السلبيه
وموقف السكان طبعا الذي سيكون سلبيا ايضا
اذا عواطف
هل من مصلحه موسكو فرمله الهجوم المضاد
واخافه اليوم اوروبا من جديد بموضوع اكبر
يعني محطه نوويه الا تصب بمصلحه روسيا
اليوم
باختصار لو سمحت يعني روسيا كان
باختصار شديد حتى اذا لم يكن لدى روسيا اي
ضلع في هذه العمليه وهي بالفعل لها علاقه
له فيه كان من حسابات ربما كيف ان الغرب
طبعا المتعاطف مع اوكرانيا سوف تثق باي
روايه تتحدث عنه اوكرانيا في تبرير
لعملياتها الهجوميه التي ربما حقيقيه
وربما هي محاوله او الصرف انذار موسكو عن
الاتجاه الرئيسي اسمح لي ان اعود الى كيف
ايضا يعني سعاده السفير اليوم عندما نتحدث
عن الفرمله الهجوم المضاد عندما نتحدث عن
هذا هذا الهجوم طبعا القوات الاوكرانيه
مستفيده بانها تستطيع الوصول الى اوديسا
بينما لا تستطيع القوات الروسيه وايضا من
جانب اخر اليوم يعني القوات الاوكرانيه
بامكان ضم بعض الجنود عن الجبهه هناك
واخذهم الى جبهات اخرى الى اي مدى يصب هذا
التفجير بمص
رؤوس عاجزه حتى لحمايه بلده محمود
حديث يقول عنا هجوم على هذا من الاربعه
مستحيلات ولكن ثانيا واحد من روسيا هي
عاجزه لتنفيذ احط عمليات الاجلاء السكان
من هذه المنطقه من ضيفه شرقيه للاسف
الشديد علاوه اليوم عندما اوكرانيا
حققت عمليه التنفيذ روسيا اطلقت النار
وكصفات مدينه خرسون للاسف الشديد هذا
اباده جماعيه
بصفه عامه كما قلت قابل ليست في صالح
اوكرانيا تدمير هذا لان كما نحن نشاهد
نتائج هذا هذا انها بصراحه كارثه
لاوكرانيا وهذا الضرر الكبير لاكتساط
اوكرانيا الانظفه غربيه عدده كبيره من
المنشات وسيطه كبيره ومصانعه مع
شكرا لكما ضيفي منك يا السفيره
من موسكو
المحلل السياسي شكرا لكم على هذه
المداخلات
نبقى مشاهدينا في الحرف اوكرانيا حيث اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على ان قواتها تسيطر
بشكل كامل على بلده برخيفكا بالقرب من
بخموت التي اتهمهم قائد مجموعه فاجنر
بالتنازل عنها جزئيا واوضحت الوزاره ان
الوحدات الروسيه نجحت في صدد هجوم شنه
مقاتل القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه مؤكده ان
تخلي القوات الروسيه المزعوم لبرخيفك لا
يتوافق مع الواقع
هذا وكشف مصدر في جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي بان الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه تخطط وتحضر لتنفيذ هجمات
ارهابيه في روسيا بما في ذلك استخدام
قنبله قذره ووفقا للمعلومات التي تم
الحصول عليها لتنفيذ هذه الخطط قامت
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه بضم
مجموعات من الطائرات الخفيفه لتوجيه ضربات
بالقاء قنابل على منشات الوقود ومواقع
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه وتم وضع خطه لنقل
وزرع ما يسمى بالقنابل القذره المجهزه
باجهزه توقيت لتفجيرها في وقت واحد في عده
مناطق سكنيه في روسيا بهدف جعلها غير
صالحه للعيش
وصف رئيس مجموعه فاقنرال المسلحه يفجين
بريجوشين حصيله الخسائر الاوكرانيه التي
اعلنتها روسيا بعد تاكيدها صد هجومين
كبيرين في اليومين بانها تخيلات وقال
بريكوجين ساخرا من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قتل 1500 جندي في يوم واحد هو مذبحه
واذا كانت ارقام الارقام طبعا التي قدمتها
الدفاع الروسيه صحيحه فهذا يعني اننا
دمرنا كوكب الارض وفق تعبيره انكشف ايضا
بان القوات الاوكرانيه استعادت جزءا من
بلده بخيفكل شمالي بخموت في شرق اوكرانيا
ووصف الامر بانه عار
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث كشفت مصادر العربيه عن
عوده المواحدات والمحادثات غير المباشره
بين الجيش والدعم السريع بتسهيل من
السعوديه والولايات المتحده في جده واوضحت
مصادر العربيه ان اجنده المفاوضات تتركز
على الترتيبات الانسانيه ووقف اطلاق النار
بالاضافه الى ان كل وفد انخرط في اجتماعات
منفصله مع مسهل عمليه الحوار مؤكده انه لم
يتم طرح اجوندا جديده في جوله المحادثات
الحاليه
هذا وعبر المفوض الاممي للاجئين
فيليبوغراند عن الصدمه جراء تقارير افادت
بمقتل عشره لاجئين على الاقل في هجوم في
الخرطوم واعتبر المفاوض الاممي للاجئين ان
كل المدنيين في السودان في خطر وفق قوله
طبعا
في اقليم دارفور يعيش الناس اوضاعا
ماساويه بسبب القتال الدائر في السودان
فقد شهدت عده مدن بالاقليم نزوحا وتشردا
كبيرا الى جانب نزوح عدد كبير من الدول
المجاوره الامر الذي دفع حاكم الاقليم الى
اعلام دارفور منطقه منكوبه تحتاج
للمساعدات فلنتابع التفاصيل
بعد اكثر من خمسين يوما من القتال في
السودان لحقت باقليم دارفور اضرار عديده
تمثلت في اللجوء والتشريد لعدد كبير من
المواطنين بهذا الاقليم حاكم اقليم دارفور
مني اركم الناوي اعلن بان اقليم دارفور
يحتاجه لمساعدات عاجله وبان هذه المنطقه
من السودان تعتبر منطقه منكوبه لذلك تحتاج
الى التدخلات العاجله في اقرب وقت
والله بنطالب والناشد المنظمات الانسانيه
والخيريه انها تجينا راجعه زي ما قالوا
تقدم يد العون لانه في ناس عانت بجد
وبالذات في موسم الخريف ده ونحن والوف
عندنا في شهر 9 وشهر خمسه واربعه والفصول
والغريب دي يعني في بيكون ركود اقتصادي
صعب جدا يعني المنظمات دي بتسهل مساهمه
كبيره لو جاءت بتساعد في هالمشاكل كثير من
البيوت
القتال هو الداير بين الجيش والدعم السريع
خلف نزوحا كبيرا با دارفور فقد تضررت
مراكز ايواء خاصه بالنازحين بغرب دارفور
تضرر معسكر نيفاشا وكساب بشمال دارفور
كمناطق يصعب ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
اليها مع ما تشهده من قتال يومي وانعدام
في السلع الاساسيه وتحول الصراع في بعض
المناطق بهذا الاقليم الى صراع الكل ضد
الكل مما خلف جرائم كثيره جدا وتعتبر
كارثيه بالنسبه للانسان الان المويه
الواحد يمشي بيت في او يجيب صف من الصباح
لحد الازر عشان يجيب برميل وينتهي اليوم
الثاني يعني معاناه لدرجه اكثر من كده
وبعدين
الماكل والمشرب في ناس كثير هيكون خارج
اليوم باليوم في سوق والاسواق هما شغاله
والله الاسعار دي مبالغه فيها يعني اسعار
يوميا يعني في اليوم ممكن يزيد حاجه
بمرتين عندك مساله جاز الجاز او الامس ب
350 البرميل
يعني فتره السبعه هي لما بقينا الفتره
النسائيه بيجوا الصباح ب 500
برميل يعني شوف اسعار غيالي كما امتدت
رقعه الصراع لتشمل مناطق من جنوب دارفور
وايضا محليات تتبع لشمال دارفور من ضمنها
محليه كتم الصراع ايضا اثر على حركه الطرق
بين المدن المختلفه هنا في اقليم دارفور
كما انه ساهم مساهمه كبيره في عدم ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه من بورسودان الى
دارفور صالح ابو علامه في قناتها العربيه
والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
التاسع مستمراتها بعد قليل
[تصفيق]
بعد اشهر من اتفاق بين البلدين اعاده فتح
السفاره الايرانيه في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه مشاهدينا
من واشنطن حيث اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه التزام واشنطن بتعزيز شركتها
الامنيه مع السعوديه بما في ذلك المبيعات
الدفاعيه والتدريبات المشتركه ومكافحه
انتشار الصواريخ والطيران المسير لدى جهات
غير حكوميه وقال بيان الوزاره قبيل زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان التعاون مع السعوديه من اجل ضمان
الاستقرار الاقليمي يظل احدى ركائز
العلاقات الثنائيه واضاف ان الشراكه
الامنيه بين البلدين قائمه على الاهتمام
المشترك بامن منطقه الخليج ومنع اي قوه
اجنبيه او اقليميه من تهديد المنطقه
العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه
ثمانيه عقود من الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين
السعوديه وامريكا
بحسب بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه فان
السعوديه والولايات المتحده تجمعهما علاقه
استراتيجيه ممتده لاكثر من 80 عاما حيث
يعد العمل على ضمان الامن الاقليمي احد
اسس العلاقه مع الرياض وتعزز العلاقه مع
الرياض امن الخليج والقدره على ردع اي
تهديد لامن المنطقه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك التزاما
بتعزيز الشراكه الامنيه مع الرياض عبر دعم
البنيه الدفاعيه الجويه والتدريبات
المشتركه وتعمل السعوديه والولايات
المتحده على حل ازمه السودان وحمايه
المدنيين وتمكين وصول المساعدات كما دعمت
السعوديه الجهود التي قامت بها الامم
المتحده في خفض التصعيد واحلال السلام في
اليمن
ورحبت الولايات المتحده بالخطوات التي
اتخذتها السعوديه لدعم اوكرانيا بما في
ذلك التعهد بتقديم مساعدات بقيمه 400
مليون دولار
هذا ووصل الى السعوديه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه لبحث تعاون الاستراتيجيه
الامريكي السعودي في القضايا الاقليميه
والعالميه ومجموعه من القضايا الثنائيه
بما في ذلك التعاون الاقتصادي والامني
وافاد مراسل العربيه ان زياره بلينكل
للسعوديه ستستغرق يومين حيث سيشارك
الاجتماع نظري لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
الامريكي كما سيحضر بلينكن مع وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اجتماعا وصريا للتحالف الدولي لهزيمه داعش
في الرياض لتسليط الضوء على الدور الحاسم
الذي يلعبه التحالف لمواجهه التهديد
المستمر لداعش
هذا وتواصل القوات المسلحه السعوديه
وبمشاركه قوات من دول مجلس التعاون
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تنفيذ
مناورات التمرين المشترك عزم النسر 23
وذلك في عدد من مناطق المملكه
وتنفذ القوات المشتركه تمرين مركز القياده
في مركز الحرب الجويه بالظهران ونفذت
القوات البريه ونظرتها الامريكيه في
ميادين مدينه الملك خالد العسكريه
بالمنطقه الشماليه تمرين الدفاع ضد اسلحه
التدمير الشامل هذا وبدات القوات البحريه
السعوديه ونظيرتها الامريكيه تنفيذ عمليات
تدريبيه في الخليج العربي كما نفذت القوات
الجويه ونظرتها الامريكيه وعدد من قوات
الدول المشاركه تدريبات لمواجهه التهديدات
الجويه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن عبر سكايب حسين عبد
الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات استاذ حسين يعني اليوم
السعوديه التي تعتبر اللاعب الاساسي يعني
الضابط لامن المنطقه عبر كل التفهمات التي
صيغه بالفتره الماضيه تاتي هذه الزياره
الامريكيه بعد زياره زياره يعني قبل
اسبوعين
ايضا زياره على مستوى مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي الى المنطقه كيف ستلاقي المساعي
السعوديه في تعزيز امن واستقرار المنطقه
مساء الخير طبعا يعني هذه اخبار جيده نحن
نرى انه اداره الرئيس
بايدن هناك تغيير كبير هناك تحسن كبير
طبعا لحسن الحظ العلاقه الدفاعيه بين
البلدين بين الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
لا تتاثر
بهويه الرئيس في البيت الابيض ولذلك نحن
نرى انه التعاون وثيق عسكريا واستخباراتيا
وتنسيقيا ان كان في هزيمه داعش او ان كان
في كل المواضيع الاخرى امن البحر الاحمر
امن الخليج باب المندب محاربه القرصنه كل
هذه المواضيع تعمل عليها البلدين منذ عقود
ولا تتاثر لحسن الحظ يعني اي اصوات سياسيه
داخل العاصمه الامريكيه
موضوع ام
ن الطقس الامريكيه السعوديه بموازاه
العلاقات السعوديه المنفتحه على الاطراف
الاخرين والتي ارستها بسياساتها الخارجيه
في الاونه الاخيره ان كان على الصين او
روسيا او اي لاعب دولي كيف سيبحث وزير
الخارجيه هذه الملفات خصوصا بانها تعتبر
هواجز لدى الامريكيه
حسن الحظ انه الاداره الامريكيه احرجت هذا
الموضوع من دائره تجاذبات السياسيه داخل
واشنطن في الماضي كنا نسمع اصوات امريكيه
معترضه على بعض القرارات السعوديه في
موضوع الطاقه والنفط هذه المره اعتقد انه
ادركت واشنطن انها تركن على السعوديه لضبط
حسن اداء واستقرار اسعار النفط في العالم
يعني ليس كل زياده في الانتاج مشكله وليست
كل اقتطاع من الانتاج مشكله هناك يعني
هناك علم خلف هذه العمليه اعتقد انه
واشنطن هذه المره ادركت انه هي تركن على
السعوديه يتثق بالقرارات السعوديه وانه
سوق
الطاقه العالمي اعتقد في هذه المرحله
مستمر على الرغم من كل الحروب يعني الرغم
من حرب روسيا واوكرانيا والعقوبات الدوليه
على روسيا ولكن مع ذلك لحسن الحظ لحسن
الحظ الاقتصاد الامريكي ايضا يعني السوق
الطاقه العالمي مستقر بسبب المجهود
السعودي
زياره تاتي ايضا بتوقيت حساس في ظل يعني
ترتيب ملفات المنطقه بظل ايضا وجود خطر هي
الحرب حرب السودان وغيرها من الملفات في
الداخل وايضا بظل الانقسام العمودي بين
قطبي العالم السعوديه اليوم هي يعني ضامن
لامن واستقرار المنطقه وايضا على مستوى
العالم اتحدثون على مستوى الطاقه وعلى
مستوى العلاقات مع الافرقه الاخرين هذه
الزياره بتوقيتها ماذا تعني
طبعا ان هناك ملفات متعدده وللاسف ان هذه
الملفات تزيد يعني مع اندل حرب السودان
ودخول الوساطه السعوديه والوساطه
الامريكيه لانهاء هذه الحرب على الخط
الملفات الشائكه ومعقده وحرب روسيا حتى
الان لا تبدو انها تنحسر يعني كل هذه
المواضيع الشائكه اعتقد انه نحن نرى
ازدياد في وتيره الزيارات للمسؤولين
الامريكيين كبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
طبعا كان جيكسار المملكه قبل اسبوعين
واليوم نرى بلينكن واعتقد انه سنرى زايدا
في هذه الوثيره بشكل اكبر في الايام
القادمه شكرا لك استاذ حسين عبد الحسين
الباحثين مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيات
حدثتنا من واشنطن
افتتحت السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض
افتتحت مجددا بحضور ممثلين من وزرتي
الخارجيه السعوديه والايرانيه اعاده
الافتتاح تاتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر من توقيع
الاتفاق السعودي الارادي باستئناف
العلاقات بينهما برعايه صينيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد حسن زارنكر
بالقائم باعمال السفاره الايرانيه في
الرياض بان اعاده افتتاح السفاره امر
ايجابي مؤكدا على ضروره عوده العلاقات لما
له من منفعه اقتصاديه وتجاريه للبلدين
والمنطقه
العلاقات بين الدولتين السعوديه وايران
ضروريه للمنطقه نرى ان عوده العلاقات
الضروريه ومستقبل العلاقات بينهما مشرق
وسيتم توسيع العلاقات التجاريه
والاقتصاديه والسياحيه المتبادله بين
البلدين وبشكل عام عوده العلاقات امر
ايجابي ويعود بالنفع على المنطقه اجمعها
[موسيقى]
كريم بنزيما يلحق بكريستيانو رونالدو الى
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم بعد الاعلان
على موافقته على الانتقال الى نادي
الاتحاد بطل الدوري هناك فبينما كانت
الاوساط الرياضيه منشغله على مدار الايام
الماضيه باعلان ريال مدريد المنافس رحيل
المهاجم كريم بنزيما قطع نادي الاتحاد
الشك باليقين واكد انتقال النجم الفرنسي
الى الفريق بعقد يمتد لثلاث سنوات
وتوجد بنزيما مشاهدينا البالغ من العمر 35
عاما بجائزه افضل لاعب في العالم العام
الماضي وكما انه فاز ايضا بخمسه وعشرين
لقبا مع نادي ريال مدريد خلال 14 موسما او
14 موسما بينها خمسه القاب لدوري ابطال
اوروبا
من الصعب التحدث بمشاعر كثيره لكن اردت ان
اشكر ريال مدريد وزملائي في الفريق لقد
كان طريقا جيدا في حياتي كنت محظوظا
بتحقيق حلم الطفوله لن انسى ريال مدريد
ابدا من المستحيل انه افضل نادي في
التاريخ لكن يعتقد ان اليوم هو الوقت
المناسب للذهاب والتعرف على تجربه جديده
اذا نجوم فازوا بالكره الذهبيه بدا الدوري
السعودي يستقدبهم وبداوا يقتنعون بقوه كره
القدم في المملكه وعلى راس هؤلاء طبعا نجم
النصر والمنتخب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الفائز بالكره الذهبيه في خمس
مناسبات لكن قبل ذلك مشاهدينا الدوري
السعودي ليس بالجديد على نجوم العالم فهو
ايضا يعني شاركت فيه ثلاثه نجوم
برازيليين سبق لهم التتويج بكاس العالم
كلب برازيلي ريفينالو ريفيلين نو المطوج
بكاس العالم لعام 1970 مع بيليه الذي لعب
طبعا للهلال في الفتره ما بين 1978 و 1981
ملاعب السعوديه احتضنت ايضا برازيلي اخر
توج بكاس العالم وهو بيبيتو الفائز
بمونديال 1994 برفقه منتخب بلاده ليلعب
لنادي اتحاد جده عام
2008 البرازيليه الثالث المتوج بكاس
العالم وهو دينيلسون الفائز بمونديال 2002
الذي مثل نادي النصر في موسم 2007 و2006
وبالتالي فان كريم بنزيما سينضم الى قائمه
طويله من النجوم العالميين ممن قصدوا
الدوري السعودي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو
الفانيلا عصام عامر الصحافي في قسم
الرياضه للحديث عن هذا الخبر انتقال
بنزيما من ريال مدريد الى الاتحاد قبل
يعني ان نبحث هذا الموضوع ساشير الى ان
الاتحاد قد اكد قبل قليل الانتقال الرسمي
للاعب ريال مدريد بنزيما الى الاتحاد
وانضمامه الى صفوف الاتحاد وبالتالي نحن
امام انتقال كامل وتام ماذا يعني هذا
الانتقال على ريال مدريد كفريق وعلى
الاتحاد خصوصا اننا نتحدث بان بنزيما
مازال حتى الساعه هو افضل لاعب بالعالم
ليس لاعب يعني افضل لاعب في السنه الماضيه
او ما قبله بدايه انتقاله من ريال مدريد
هي يعني بحد ذاتها ممكن تكون خساره لريال
مدريد بما انه قائد الفريق الان وواحد من
اهم اللاعبين مساهم في العديد من الاهداف
كان حاسما
في مباريات عديده
اما بالنسبه لانتقاليه لنادي الاتحاد هو
اكيد سيعطي اضافه للدوري السعودي ويعطي
زخم اكبر يلتحق الان برونالدو وكما قلت هو
الان لا يزال افضل لاعب في العالم يعني هو
اخر من توجب الكره الذهبيه وليس لاعب كان
مثلا على سبيل المثال حبيس دكه البدلاء
اكثر لاعب بريال مدريد له تاثير على
الجمهور وحتى داخل الفريق اليوم ينتقل الى
الاتحاد طب هناك نقطه اساسيه يتحدث عنها
الكثيرين بالساعات الماضيه بان معظم
اللاعبين ينتقلون الى الفرق السعوديه باخر
عقود تعاقديه لهم كيف يمكن شرح الاستفاده
من هؤلاء اللاعبين الذين يعتبرون اليوم من
اشهر اللاعبين في العالم
كريم زي ما تقلل للدوري السعودي يعني لن
يعطي اضافه فقط على المستوى الرياضي هو هو
لاعب لديه عشاق ولديه مشجعين الذين
سيتبعونه الى الدوري السعودي مثل ما حدث
مع رونالدو الان بنزيما لا يزال يملك
قاعده جماهيريه كبيره ويملك تاثير كبير
هذه الاشياء كلها يعني سينقلها معه في
الدوري السعودي وبالتاكيد سيعطي الاضافه
للدوري السعودي هل سيفتح الباب امام
مشاركه مواهب جديده ويعني شابه ونجوم
عالميين الى صفوف السعوديه بكل تاكيد بكل
تاكيد يعني اكيد اللاعبين الشباب الان
يرون بان بنزيما انتقل لرونالدو انتقل
الانديه السعوديه تذكر الان في المواقع
العالميه الجميع اصبح يعرف الانديه
السعوديه الهلال لعب في نهائي كاس العالم
للانديه بنزيما ايضا سيشارك في كاس العالم
للانديه مع نادي الاتحاد وممكن ان يصل
يعني الى نهائي نصف النهائي كل هذه
الاشياء اكيد يعني
نتحدث عن كريستيانو رونالدو عن بنزيما عن
ايضا الحديث عن ميسي والان هناك حديث عن
مدرج كل هؤلاء حملوا وحصلوا على الكره
الذهبيه هل اليوم العين على اللاعبين
الذين حملوا الكره الذهبيه للانضمام الى
الانديه الاساسيه اتحدث هنا
بالانديه السعوديه ممكن الان لان الدوري
السعودي في طور الانتشار ولكن على المدى
البعيد او في المستقبل القريب ايضا سيكون
ايضا التركيز على اللاعبين الشباب
للانضمام الى الدوري السعودي لان يعني
اللي سبقوهم هم لاعبين حملوا الكره
الذهبيه ولكن مع مرور الوقت اكيد سيكون
هناك لاعبين شبان ينضمون الى الدوري
السعودي
انضمام هؤلاء اللاعبين الكبار الى الانديه
السعوديه بعد عمليه التغيير والنقله
بالانديه نتحدث بان الانديه الاساسيه
اليوم اصبحت مع صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي
الى اي مدى هذا يشكل يعني عنصر راحه نفسيه
لهؤلاء لاننا نتحدث عن عقود كبيره اكيد
خصصت الانديه والتي شملت اربعه انديه
اساسيه هي من من ستكون يعني ذات هيكله
افضل ومن اهدافها رفع ايرادات الرابطه
السعوديه من 450 مليون ريال الى الى
تقريبا اثنين مليار ريال كل هذه العوامل
يعني ستساهم في اعطاء يعني راحه للانديه
في التفاوض وممكن حتى يعني انه اللاعبين
يشوفوا انه هذا مشروع افضل وينتقل للدوري
السعودي
[موسيقى]
الى الكويت حيث اغلقت صناديق الاقتراع
الانتخابات مجلس الامه لعام 2023 في نحو
118 مركزا يتنافس في هذه الانتخابات 207
مرشحين ومرشحه وهو العدد الاقل منذ عام
2008 تتارجح في هذه الانتخابات ارى
الناخبين في رغباتهم بالمشاركه وعدمها حيث
يتوجه اليوم اكثر من 700 الف ناخب وناخبه
للادلاء باصواتهم لمرشح واحد فقط
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
لانتهاكها خصوصيه الاطفال السلطات
الامريكيه تغرم مايكروسوفت بعشرين مليون
دولار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اليوم الرابع عشر من
الاضرابات العامه في فرنسا ضد قانون
التقاعد انطلقت المظاهره الرئيسيه في
باريس حيث بدات التجمعات في ساحه قريبه من
الجمعيه الوطنيه هذا وقد اعلنت السلطات
الفرنسيه عن نشر ما لا يقل عن احد عشر الف
عنصر للقوات الشرطه والدرك لتامين
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات التي ستنطلق في
جميع انحاء البلاد بدعوى من الاتحاد
النقابي ضد قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي
اثار في الفتره الماضيه موجه غضب عارمه في
صفوف الفرنسيين طبعا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الامير هاري يقف في منصه الشهود لمقاضاه
المجموعه المالكه لصحيفه ذمرر البريطانيه
التي يتهمها بالتنصت على هاتفه وانتهاك
خصوصيته بصوره غير قانونيه ولكن ما هي
ابرز ادعاءات هذه حول قضيه انتهاك الصحافه
لخصوصياتهم هي 33 نموذجا من القصص الخبريه
المنشوره في مجموعه زمرد من اصل طبعا 147
قصه التطفل غير القانوني على خصوصيه هذه
وصل الى ملاعب مدرسه ايتن وهناك قصتان
تناقشان تناقشان طبعا الاصابات الرياضيه
للامير بعدما نشرت صحيفه ديلي ميرو عام
2000 ان الامير هاري اجرى عمليه جراحيه
بسيطه في ذراعه بعد اصابه مرتبطه بالكره
القدم
والتي توضح بالتفصيل نصائح محدده قيل ان
الاطباء قدموها للصبي البالغ من العمر 16
عاما طبعا بعد 11 شهرا ذكرت صحيفه ساندي
ميرور في تقرير بعنوان
بان الاطباء امروا الامير بالتوقف عن لعب
عن اللعب بسبب اصابه في الظهر طبعا بحسب
هذه الصحيفه ايضا بعض من القصص الثلاث 33
تغطي شؤون الاسره الداخليه احدها نشرتها
مجله في ديسمبر من العام 2003 تعرض ايضا
تفاصيل الخلاف بين الامير والامير ويليام
حول سلوك رئيس فريق خدم والدتهما السابق
المحكمه ستتطرق ايضا الى القصص المعروفه
عن الامير الشاب مثل شرب الكحول وتعاطي
المخدرات وغير هذه القصص بعدما ذكرت احدى
قصص ساندي ميرير عام 2002 بان الامير
تشارلز انذاك اعطها لتحذيرا صارما متعلقا
بتدخين الحشيش
تغطيه اعلاميه كبيره لمعركه الامير هاري
القضائيه ضد ناشري صحيفه ديلي ميرو وادعاء
خرق خصوصيته في حمله لفضح مخالفات الصحافه
الشعبيه البريطانيه من اجل انقاذها كمهنه
وفق زعمه
الامير هاري هو اول افراد العائله الملكه
يدلي بشهادته في المحكمه منذ 130 عاما
وبعد اداء القسم استهل محامي الدفاع
مجموعه صحف ميرور اندروغرين بسؤال الامير
هاري فيما يتعلق مقالات قال انها تستند
الى موده تم الحصول عليها بشكل غير قانوني
اعداءه للصحافه كان واضحا في الرد على
اسئله هيئه الدفاع الصحيفه من رمي اللوم
عليها في الحاجه التي اودت بحياه والدته
ديانا الى ما عاناه من اضطراب مع عائلته
واصدقائه من خلال جمع معلومات لمقالتها عن
طريق الخداع وانشطه غير مشروعه متسائلا عن
علاقه اموره الشخصيه بالمصلحه العامه التي
شكلت كيف ينظر اليه من قبل عامه الناس
شاهدا فحسب بل انه ايضا المدعي في هذه
القضيه وما يجعلها محاكمه ضخمه انه احد
افراد العائله الملكه وابن الملك تشارلز
يخوض معركه قضائيه ضد احد اكبر نشر الصحف
بريطانيا
يوم ثاني من التدقيق في مضمون ادعاءات
مبرمجا في جلسه محاكمه التاريخيه لكن قرار
الحكم النهائي في قضيته سيتطلب سنوات
لقناتي العربيه والحدث مصطفى زارو لندن
تنضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن عروب عبد
الحق مراسله العربيه عروب سابدا بمجريات
هذه المحاكمه ما الجديد فيها والى اين
ستصل
طبعا يعني كما ذكرتي كانت هناك تفاصيل
ومجريات يعني المحكمه بشكل تفصيلي وطويل
امتدت ساعات عده غادر الامير هاري منذ
قرابه الساعتين قاعه المحكمه العليا هنا
من خلفي بعد امضاءه حوالي الخمس الى ست
ساعات من الاستجواب من قبل محامي الدفاع
اندرو جرين محامي دفاع مجموعه مرر للنشر
التي يرفع الامير هاري قضيه ضدها بسبب
انتهاكات في خصوصيته واستخدام وسائل قال
بانها غير قانونيه للحصول على معلومات
كانت مسؤوله بحسب قوله عن تخريب علاقته
بكثير من المقربين منه وتخريب سمعته سمعته
ايضا بين بين المقربين منه وبين او في
بريطانيا بشكل عام طبعا كانت هذه المحاكمه
فيها رمزيه كبيره للامير هاري وبريطانيا
بشكل عام بالنسبه للامير هذه هو اخذ على
عاتقه مهمه تغيير المشهد الاعلامي هنا في
بريطانيا وذلك بسبب يعني
رغبته بمحاسبه المسؤولين عن تخريب سمعته
وعن الاساءه لوالدته الراحله الاميره
ديانا التي بطبيعه الحال هو يلوم الصحافه
صحافه التابلود في انها سبب في في وفاتها
في وفاتها اما بالنسبه لبريطانيا طبعا هي
اللحظه تاريخيه لانها المحاكمه الاولى
لفرد رفيع من افراد العائله الملكيه منذ
ما يزيد عن 130 عام اي منذ عام
1891 وبالتالي يعني هذه المحاكمه كانت
تستند كما ذكرتي الى 55 صفحه هي بيان
شهاده مكونه من 55 صفحه تستند الى اكثر من
30 مقاله اخباريه في هذه المحكمه تم تناول
هذه المقالات مقاله تلو الاخرى بشكل
تفصيلي كبير سئلت عن يعني سئل فيها الامير
هاري عن تف التفاصيل في هذه في هذه
المقالات وكان هناك حتى يعني
ضغط من محامي الدفاع فيما اذا كانت هذه
المقالات الاخباريه هي سبب في يعني شعور
هاري بانه متوتر او شعور هاري بانه يعني
شعر
بالريبه من من جميع من حوله بسبب هذه
المقالات الاخباريه وبالتالي طبعا هذه
المحكمه مستمره من المتوقع ان يعود الامير
هادي الى المحكمه غدا القاضي طبعا اعطى
مده قصوى للاستماع لافاده هاري حتى الساعه
الثانيه عشره بعض ظهرا غدا وبالتالي تنتهي
هذه الافاده طبعا من الجدير بالذكر ان
القاضي شعر بالاستياء من غياب الامير هاري
في اليوم الاول من المحاكمه وكان يعني كما
سمعنا بانه متفاجئ من غيابه في هذه في
اليوم الاول وبطبيعه الحال نحن نعلم بان
القاضي سيكون صاحب قرار
اي حكم في هذه القضيه شكرا لك عروب عبد
الحق مراسلات العربيه حدثنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
توفي العميل السابق لمكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه
الذي اعتبر احد اشهر الجواسيس الذين عملوا
لصالح روسيا في واشنطن داخل سجن فلورنسا
في ولايه كولورادو الامريكيه توفي عن عمر
ناهزت 79 عاما وكان هنسا عميلا لصالح اف
بي اي منذ عام
1976 قبل ان يتعاون مع المخابرات
السوفياتيه منذ عام 1985 الى عام 1991 ومن
بعدها مع المخابرات الروسيه التي زودها
بالكثير من الوثائق والمعلومات الحساسه
التي كانت السلطات الامريكيه تسمح له
بالاطلاع عليها
[موسيقى]
انتهاك خصوصيه الاطفال والاحتفاظ
ببياناتهم دون العوده لاهاليهم وموافقتهم
هي اتهامات تواجهها شركه تكنولوجيا
العملاقه
لجنه التجاره الاتحاديه الامريكيه اعلنت
بان مايكروسوفت ستدفع 20 مليون دولار
لتسويه هذه الاتهامات والتي وجهتها لها
اللجنه بخصوص الاحتفاظ ببيانات الاطفال
بطريقه غير قانونيه واضافت اللجنه هنا في
بيان بان الشركه جمعت معلومات شخصيه من
الاطفال المشتركين بنظام اكس بوكس للالعاب
الفيديو طبعا دون اخطار الوالدين او حتى
الحصول على موافقتهم كما يلزم الامر
الصادر او يلزم هذا الامر الصادر عن
اللجنه مايكروسوفت باتخاذ خطوات لتحسين
اجراءات الحمايه وتحديدا حمايه الخصوصيه
لمستخدمي نظام اكس بوكس وبرامج الفيديو من
الاطفال تحديدا وهنا قالت اللجنه بانها
ستوسع نطاق قانون حمايه الخصوصيه وخصوصا
خصوصيه الاطفال على الانترنت ليشمل طبعا
جميع الشركات الناشره لالعاب والعاب
الفيديو التي تشارك مايكروسوفت بيانات
الاطفال معها مايكروسوفت بدورها هنا
اعترفت بالفعل لكنها بررته بانه خطا فني
من النظام يحتفظ بالبيانات تلقائيا مؤكده
بانها ستحل هذه المشكله قريبا
[موسيقى]
من الولايات المتحده الى جارتها كندا حيث
بدات موجه جديده من الحرائق في مدينه اوتا
والكنديه حيث افاد عمده المدينه الى ان
النيران لا تزال مشتعله والدخان يغطي
السماء المدينه بشكل كامل فلنتابع
في الختام تذكير بابرز العناوين
خطر تفجير سد نوفا كخوف كي يرتفع مع منسوب
تسربي مياهه والاستخبارات الامريكيه تتهم
موسكو بالهجوم
بعد توصيات سعوديه امريكيه طرف الصراع في
السودان يستانفان محادثات وقف اطلاق النار
في جده
وتزامنا مع زياره بلينكن الى السعوديه
واشنطن تؤكد التزامها بتعزيز الشراكه
الامنيه مع الرياض
بعقد يمتد لثلاث سنوات اتحاد جده سعودي
يتفق مع كريم بنزيما قادما من ريال مدريد
الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا
شكرا لحسن المتابعه والان الى 360 مع
زميله راويه راويه مساء الخير ماذا لديك
اهلا بك ليال سنتحدث طبعا عن الاتهامات
المتبادله بين روسيا واوكرانيا حول من دمر
السد بالاضافه طبعا الى السودان ومجريات
الاحداث هناك والانتخابات في الكويت
تابعينا تفضلوا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات